全然乗ったことないって言ったら、ただ歩くだけなら誰でもできますから。
乗ってればいいわけです。
そこは引いてくれないから。
周りにインストラクターがついて、後ろからついていく。
速い足って言って、揺れなきゃ別に落ちませんので、ただ歩くだけ。
その来た子の一人は、僕が教えた子だから、ある程度乗れるんだけど、お友達連れてきたら、彼は全然乗れないので、
だからゆっくり歩いて、1時間で探索を。
すごい楽しかったです。
山の中を歩くときにして、山の中じゃない。
養護クラブのコースじゃなくて。
ある程度山のコースが決まってて、ずっと歩いて行くんですよね。
1時間くらいのコース。
すごく楽しめることがある。
それですか。
白馬の山の上で外場って、馬が何頭も用意されている。
予約すれば。
本当に乗ったことない人も、インストラクターが前に着いて、本当におとなしい馬抱き揃えているから、
半島、4島くらいで、白馬の山の上で。
それ気持ち良さそうです。
いや、全然素人でも大丈夫だ。
そうなんです。
コロンビアはこういうことだ。
昔から。
ありそうですね。コロンビアはね。
ありそうな。
コロンビアはね。
ところが、朝早くに出て山を一周します。
昔ご飯と、あるところで食べて、夜ご飯。
そんなに?
一日ライド。
そうそう、一日。
夜まで。
すごい。
ロバを。
スピカをつけて、
リンコをつけて、
みんな音楽をかけて。
楽しそう。
えっと、
バーみたいな。
飲みながら、
音楽を飲みながら。
ちょっと、2分だけで、
ちょっと酔っ払いながら。
そうそう、酔っ払いだから。
とってもいい。
音楽のスピーカー乗っけたロバがずっとついてきて。
そうそう。